we are back with a Fox News Alert weekly
jobless claims soar to a record-breaking
6.6 million as the economy reels over
the coronavirus that number is much
higher than economists had predicted
they were thinking between 3 and 5
million people losing their jobs as
strict measures to contain the disease
have closed businesses and brought the
country to a standstill in many parts
Brian
all right this new number completely
eclipses last week's jobless claims we
were at 3.3 million file for
unemployment so let's bring in Steinem
Senator Marco Rubio said I know
personally that you worked extremely
hard especially as it goes to small
business with the 2.2 trillion does this
number represent a previous move by
employers to get rid of these employees
and could they be brought back in order
to get some of the money you put aside
for them it's a stunning number and it
does represent the people who've lost
their jobs probably all throughout last
week which is what we were warning about
can I say something else was without you
know frightening everybody or freaking
everyone out the true number is actually
much higher we know for example that
there's probably no state in the country
who has an unemployment system that is
prepared to take in the vast volume of
people that are trying to reach them in
Florida and all over the country they're
just being overwhelmed no system is set
up for 50,000 people to call in a day
and or try to reach them so the number
is probably much higher than that the
true number and that is why there was
such a sense of urgency to get that bill
passed last week and why we have such a
sense of urgency now to get the Paycheck
protection program up and running
senator what's your recommendation to
small business owners I have a friend I
was talking to her and she said I want
to be able to pay my employees how do I
get that money we've gone to the bank
the banks aren't familiar with what
we're supposed to be doing she's gone to
that website so many times and she still
has questions well that makes should be
familiar by now I would tell you that my
advice that I give every small
businesses if you have an existing
banking relationship especially if it's
one of the larger national banks but it
but he can be a community bank as well
reach out to them and me
I know that as last night all the
various different large banks that have
branches all over the country and I
think a growing number of community
banks are preparing to gear up and start
the paycheck protection program which
will allow a small business to go in and
get 250 percent of their monthly payroll
which at which they can use and don't
have to pay back if they use it for
payroll benefits or employees rent lease
or utility and so everyone's working
overtime to get that program up and
running the goal is to start Friday
absolutely astride a with the
applications the applications are now
available online people can start
filling them out but I would start with
you you have an existing banking
relationship you should reach out for
them again absolutely and the sooner the
better
and of course senator the whole idea
behind this particular paycheck
protection program was so that the
employers who are clearly struggling
because their businesses may not be open
to the public right now except remotely
or via online this would keep the the
people who they employ on the payroll
and if they don't want to have to pay
the loan back keep them on the payroll
but if they cut them loose then they're
gonna have to pay the money back
yeah and we're talking about small
businesses the overwhelming majority of
small businesses for them their
employees or people they know they're
not some number on a ledger thousands of
employees scattered all over the world
these are people they know they know
their families in many cases they've
worked for them for a long time the only
reason why they're not still on payroll
they've had to lay them off is because
it comes the small business of making
any money the government has forced them
to close and so they would prefer to
keep them on payroll and they can use
that money to hire back the people that
have been laid off they even pay them
back pay for the two weeks they might
have been laid off but that's the goal
is to keep people on a paycheck and not
having to be on a phone for two hours on
hold just to try to get through to the
unemployment office I still believe the
overwhelming and the majority of
Americans would rather have a paycheck
from a job there's to have a government
check from unemployment so we had
senator Graham on yesterday or the day
before the world
together and he said look all these
states aren't prepared Louisiana their
unemployment Department was crude their
program program was failing and it
collapsed three or four times that's
before this number came out so having
said that the way we're attacking the
virus can we also attack the
unemployment system in these states is
there an effort made right now to get a
software company to design something
that all 50 states can actually acquire
well I don't know about all 50 states I
can tell you you know Florida is
obviously in the process of trying to
build up their capacity both their
website and their call center but again
it's the sheer volume that we're talking
about I want to be fair here in a
perfect world we have systems that work
great but the reality of it is that the
the sheer volume is something you can't
possibly prepare for me look every time
that we try to get critical about
something I think it is important to
remind everybody that what we are facing
is unprecedented whether it's in the
healthcare realm or the economic realm
no nation on earth has ever faced what
the world is facing right now and if we
have a lot of people out there working
really hard none of this is deliberate
there are gonna be some hiccups along
the way because we have never faced
anything like that said no my hope is
that everyone is putting in all the
effort necessary to correct these things
whether it's for the unemployment system
whether it's getting tests out there
whether it's building up our ventilator
capacity and you name it I know there's
a lot of people working very hard to
make those things better we all want to
get better senator the stay-at-home
order goes into effect in your state
tonight in our state in New York our our
governor said that now he's predicting
the apex will be at the end of April we
still have another month to go what do
you say first of all Florida in fairness
Florida's had a stay at home over just
because it didn't come out of
Tallahassee the truth is every city and
county in the state had ordered the
varying degrees the second reality of it
is everything's closed I don't know
where you would go if you didn't want to
stay at home at this point
so I think much of that's already in
place and and I think all that happened
what yesterday were governor De Santis
is he from Tallahassee
he basically formalized what was already
in place look I think for Florida I
can't speak for New York and other
places but I think for for
the next 30 days are gonna be our
toughest that's according to all the
models and as I tell everybody how long
this goes on and how difficult it is a
lot of that will depend on out what is
what job we do all of us collectively at
staying away from each other and slowing
the rate of infection because that's the
key here we have to slow the rate of
infection so that we don't overwhelm the
hospitals because everybody got sick at
one time and we can use this time to
build capacity and the quicker we can
build up that capacity including the
development of antivirals the quicker we
can get back to some semblance of
normalcy
I still think social distancing and
limits on large crowds will be with it
for some time but but that's the
situation we're in now is not something
that would anyone believe could be
sustained for a year six months or
anything like that so I think a lot of
that depends on what we do right now and
that is every single water boat that's
right because you know ultimately the
social distancing is leading to a social
solidarity of sorts senator because I
think after we heard from the president
a couple of days ago where the numbers
were bleak and the diagnosis was dire I
think it finally dawned on a lot of
people you know what this could be the
fight for our lives
yeah either doesn't there's nothing that
brings people closer together than when
they realize that what they don't have
in common is smaller than what they do
have in common this is a disease that
infects the heads of state and a 90 year
old retiree at a nursing home it infects
Democrats Republicans independents it
doesn't discriminate in terms of who is
both active and so I think this is
something that we all recognize there
are no winners here there are no winners
all of them are impacted by this and so
I just tell everybody that ultimately
when it comes to this there are no sides
I hate hearing that there's one side
versus there are no sides on this
there's only one side that's humanity
against the virus look we can win we
will win this battle and I think how
quickly we win and how decisively we win
depends on every single one of us doing
our part from the people at home that
are staying home to the scientists and
and the brave and incredible doctors and
nurses on the frontline who by the way
if I could have 10 seconds to thank them
if you look at and we've
hope that this continues to be the case
look at the number of cases we have and
the number of deaths there are countries
out there that have a quarter of our
deaths or half of our sari half of our
cases and four times our death and I
think at least up up to now I can say
that that is a testament so the
incredible work of our health care
workers on the front line people working
double shift and many cases putting
their own safety and health at risk
thank thank you to them god bless them
and their families for what they're
doing yeah we got to get the materials
and we got to get them some relief
because they can't work 24 hours a day
senator one day we're going to talk
about the jobless claims and they're
going to be palatable and tolerable and
on the positive but that's just not
today
senator Rubio thanks so much thanks
senator thank you guys safe